que pensez vous madame de l'ignoble
trafic des petits ramasseurs de balles
bonne question j'ignorais jusqu au
trafic mais s'il ya un trafic je trouve
que c'est pas bien
chaque année il va m'en 15 à 20% et en
dernier recours la fédération l'été
venir du brésil il voyage dans des
conditions d'hygiène épouvantables il y
en a 10 à 20% qui meurent dans des
soutes de du bateau et personne ne le
sait ça il faut absolument le faire
savoir
ils voyagent dans des conditions
d'hygiène épouvantables il y en a même
qui ont perdu la vie quoi dans ce cas là
c'est ignoble mais bon voilà je suis pas
dire comme ça brûle brûle pourquoi je ne
sais pas quoi dire c'est sûr c'est
ignoble
oui bien sûr que ça me choque ces petits
ramasseurs de balles dont il n'avait pas
de famille qui ont été recrutés au
brésil après ont été lâchés dans le bois
qui sont devenus travesti pour la
plupart oui à la oumma prendrait une des
nouvelles tout à fait ignoble c'est
vraiment perdu là ne sais pas quoi vous
dire parce que c'est horrible c'est
horrible mais je pense qu'il ya un an
nous cache beaucoup de choses dont vous
avez trouvé un petit peu fatigués
certains amateurs de balle certains oui
parce qu'ils sont essoufflés quand même
ils sont
il y en a pas assez pour le nombre qu'il
faut c'est qu'ils sont essoufflés c'est
sans aucun doute les brésiliens qui ont
aucune condition physique
oui c'est ça c'est ça allait en france
ils pourraient trouver honnêtement mieux
que d'aller chercher les étrangers pas
pour faire les ramasseurs de balles
c'est ce qu'il devienne pas le tournoi
non
certains finissent qui ont travesti dans
le bois d'autres sont abattus et où ils
revendent les peaux hâlées tannerie
est-ce que ce que vous me dites c'est
voilà on l'a appris ce matin c'est
dramatique
je sais pas il faudrait il faudrait le
mettre dans les journaux pendant que les
gens mois soit au courant pour qu'on
puisse enfin manoise heures c'est bien
j'étais pas du tout au courant je suis
choquée j'ai déjà acheté un sac à main
ou autres accessoires confectionnés avec
la peau d'un petit ramasseur de balles
non non jamais si demain vous proposer
un sac deux fois moins cher est ce que
vous feriez attention honnêtement c'est
ici que le ramasseur de balle vous lâche
et aurier ou pas non non à mon avis non
maintenant que je sais l'histoire je
vais à mon avis c'est non je ne serai
pas non
soyez prêt doit adopter un petit
ramasseur de balle à la fin du tournoi
non nous on peut pas s'y plier
l'abattoir où seriez prête à acheter un
sac à main confectionner clapot dante
ramasseur de balles même si c'est deux
fois moins cher non même
hmm hmm hmm donné je le ferai pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus